hey what is up guys MP PhD here and this
is a full view of the Samsung Galaxy s7
so this is a phone that's similar in a
lot of ways to its predecessor the one
that came before it which would be the
galaxy s6 so the easiest way to talk
about this phone and to completely
understand it is to look at all the
differences between it and the one that
came before it so this is everything you
need to know that's new and different
about the galaxy s7 so first of all the
body is slightly different it's slightly
upgraded and most people hear that to
mean it got thinner but this phone is
actually slightly thicker and I'm
calling that the upgrade because it's
allowing one a much smaller camera bump
on the back and to a much smaller home
button / the fingerprint reader bump on
the front actually had a lot less
accidental home button presses with this
phone so that's nice and the phone is
still pretty thin but the extra space
inside is packing a much larger 3000
milliamp hour battery so that's pretty
important and then they focused on the
shape and the hand a little bit more so
the edges are left sharp the phone is
easier to pick up and hold and the back
glass is more rounded on the sides like
the galaxy note 5 and then the rest is
all the same premium materials from last
year so Gorilla Glass 4 on the front and
back and then metal rails on the sides
and really nice buttons I don't think
Samsung gets enough credit for how nice
the buttons are they pretty much have
the power button and volume buttons on
point so overall you get the idea that
the build is slightly improved but still
very familiar in fact this is definitely
still the slipperiest phone I've ever
held or used alongside the note 5 like
this has slipped out of my pocket while
sitting in a car multiple times
oh yeah overall the shape and build of
this phone is definitely one of those
incremental improvements from last year
ok the next difference is IP 68 this
phone is now totally dust sealed and
water-resistant so you can use it in the
rain or near a pool or at a beach or get
splashed or whatever it's fine and it
does it all internally so there's no
like weird flaps or anything over the
USB ports or the headphone jack I love
that the design stays the hit as it gets
waterproofed here the one downside is
definitely the speakers the speakers
suffer massively here pretty sure the
galaxy s7 just got the biggest downgrade
of any speakers on a smartphone they're
now way tenure and
distorted sounding and he can blame that
fully on the waterproofing so the galaxy
s7 also got the micro SD card slot back
I did not expect that to actually happen
I threw that out there in an older like
predictions video as a sort of a oddball
feature that might happen but you do
actually have it now you do have
expandable storage in the galaxy s7 and
of course you can't have a new flagship
phone without all your new flagship
specs and you get all of that here so in
the US that's the Snapdragon 820 chip
Adreno 430 and 4 gigabytes of ram and
performance is definitely up to snuff to
match this is a really quick and snappy
phone again like the galaxy s6 was and
we're getting much improved Ram
management as well that's big here I'm
glad to see this phone handle
multitasking that much better than its
predecessor which kind of occasionally
had issues holding apps and RAM with
metal and glass it still does get a bit
warm even with the new internal cooling
but nothing too severe just a little
warm to the touch when you're gaming for
a while or doing some heavy browsing but
just with everyday use it's fine
wireless charging heats up a bit but
I'll talk about that later
so yeah this phone is fast again that's
one of its biggest strengths and
definitely one of the biggest reasons to
get it so the last but not least
actually the biggest difference with the
new s7 is the new camera this new 12
megapixel camera this is my favorite
camera on any smartphone right now and
that's putting it on top of a very good
heap of other smartphone cameras out
there and I got to say there is no
shooter that consistently makes me feel
as confident as a photo and video taker
as the galaxy s7 and that's what really
makes a good photo experience for me so
the camera app opens with that double
top of the home button really quick from
anywhere again super fast and it's
immediately ready for a shot there's no
shutter lag or anything it's very quick
to just grab a photo and a lot of people
look at the new 12 megapixel photo
number and think oh wait that's less
megapixels than last year it's not a big
deal 12 megapixels is still plenty and
these pixels are now larger which along
with the optical image stabilization and
the huge F 1.7 aperture should help a
lot with low-light
should the photo quality in auto mode is
again very typical Samsung so very
bright punchy colors lots of saturation
and contrast and sharpening they've been
doing this forever so I get it
one thing that's more notable is that F
1.7 aperture
it's so easy to blow backgrounds
out-of-focus even in broad daylight with
normal subjects if you get close enough
to the subject you can get that blurry
background which is pretty crazy and the
new dual pixel autofocus handles the
shallow depth of field really well
pretty much always nails it
so photos pretty much always looks solid
coming off this phone I'd say the
biggest weakness is it tends to
overexpose a bit in daylight conditions
there are definitely more blown
highlights than crushed shadows although
throughout the pictures I've taken it's
actually not the best in low-light
here's an example of the exact same
picture I took on the galaxy s7 versus
my Nexus 6p now Nexus is haven't even
always had the best image processing but
it clearly beats the s7 here so I would
have liked to have seen
I guess less grain from the s7 camera
and low-light and a little bit more
control exposure during the day here's
the thing though that autofocus is the
best part of this new camera and it's
crazy fast also in video mode it's just
as fast making this pretty much the
ideal for high quality video if you want
to shoot 4k video in the easiest
possible way and guarantee usable
footage this phone is the one to have
over all the fast autofocus combined
with the fast aperture and the fast
camera app make this the fastest
smartphone camera alongside the iPhone
and it's a pleasure to use for that
reason oh and that front-facing camera
is not bad also five megapixels and also
an F 1.7 aperture and an even wider
angle than the back camera it's not
quite as sharpened or oversaturated but
it takes a pretty good selfie if you're
into that so there you have it a couple
of incremental but important changes
that make the galaxy s7 a different
beast plus I guess all the things about
the galaxy s6 that were already pretty
great the best display in any smartphone
the 5.1 inch quad HD Super AMOLED that
gets super bright the premium materials
the fast home button fingerprint reader
that's I think second only to touch ID
and some quick charging and wireless
charging of a new larger battery and the
actual life for me with a larger battery
was really impressive too I would give
myself like a B+ or a minus four as far
as how long this lasts during the day
pretty much never had to charge it
before the end of the day and I was
getting somewhere between five to five
and a half hours of screen on time
typically which is a big improvement
over the notably bad battery life of the
galaxy s6 so
something I was really excited to see
and you also still have fast-charging
you still have wireless charging you
still have fast wireless charging it
does get a little bit warm to the touch
when your wireless charging but other
than that pretty much no complaints
about the new battery now it's
definitely not perfect it still has its
flaws I made an entire video about that
and if you want to watch that it'll be
linked in this corner or below that like
button and it's missing a couple things
you know it doesn't have an IR blaster
some people were confused about the
dropping of that it's also like I
mentioned the slipperiest phone ever and
definitely looks and feels better with a
case or even better a nice skin on it
plus you kind of hide the fingerprints
and make it easier to hold I'll link the
D brand skin below I think that mat
looks clean and it's definitely still
not everyone's favorite software so this
Samsung scan on top of Android obviously
since it's Android you can still go to
town with the skins and custom launchers
and really make it your own but someone
like me will do that within minutes of
setting it up someone who's not really
into it might take a while and might not
like it out the box but overall I really
like this phone some of the little stuff
that used to be third-party apps Samsung
is picking up on it and building it into
their own software so stuff like the
always-on display is a nice touch so for
example since it's always an AMOLED
display you can choose to always have a
clock calendar or still image when the
phone is sleeping and it avoids burnin
by moving around the display
periodically doesn't burn too much
battery I think it's cool if you use a
calendar a lot it would be cool to have
that always on I'm not sure why you want
a still image but hey there's always
that option but yeah it's taken a lot of
stuff like this and adding it into their
own software so if you don't find it on
day one then you'll probably find it a
little while down the road after using
this phone for a while but at the end of
the day the big question is is this
galaxy s7 worth the upgrade over
whatever phone you have now if you have
something like a galaxy s6 or even a
high-end phone from last year it might
not be worth all the changes the couple
of things you do get if you're really
really into video this is the best video
camera on a smartphone now and if you're
really into having a better battery life
this is definitely a better battery life
than the galaxy s6 but if you're gonna
upgrade if you have to and you're not
really sure I would at least opt for the
galaxy s7 edge which is a little bit
bigger but you also get those edge
features and you get an even larger
battery for even better battery life
overall a pretty well-rounded experience
nope
that was totally intended so that's been
it thanks for watching this review video
hopefully enjoyed it feel free to give
it a thumbs up if you do and I'll talk
to you guys in the next one peace